these oligarchs and the way that like
the oligarchs have been punished
globally do you think it's fair
i mean
like roman abramovich right the guy who
owns chelsea he's a very famous oligarch
um
i don't know you there's all these
sanctions being put on he can't sell his
team if he is gonna sell a team he has
to go through the united uh kingdom and
they have to approve of it the team
can't i guess even profit right now
there's all these like weird rules that
are been put on they have like limited
amount of money that they can spend on
even travel etcetera
early season tickets yeah only season
ticket holders can come to games they
can't basically make any additional new
money it feels to me like they are that
these sanctions are are are happening to
these russian oligarchs in hopes that
the oligarchs will put pressure on putin
i mean i i don't think
what's his i don't think uh abramovich
has lived in russia in years
decades maybe
yeah i mean
this is like what people going after
sponsors to try to get to the person
yeah
it's it's people look for the leverage
points they have is it
fair probably not on the sort of
individual standpoint
but is it reasonable
versus like our other options probably
so basically what are they doing these
are like the only people who we assume
have access to
uh putin yeah so they're trying to not
even access to influence over maybe
right yeah
and to be fair
i mean i guess if you dig on any sports
owner they probably got some money doing
some [ __ ] up things that's probably
how you get that rich every billionaire
but yeah but if you got a problem with
russia and the way he capitalized was
buying you know the all these properties
or these oil companies for pennies on
the dollar when the ussr fell then it's
like all right well you're tied to this
guy that's how you got your power yeah
so i'm gonna go after you if i'm going
after him well you're not tied to him
that's the thing it's not like he even
gave he even made them the oligarchs he
came after that so if he made all these
people olga i'd be like okay well putin
put all these people in position the
power they put him in power yeah the
oligarchs place putin in there yeah so
it's like
you're punishing putin by punishing the
oligarchy it weirdly seems unfair to my
understanding is they remain close is
that wrong well they have to right so if
you're thinking if he still has like he
got putin elected and then putin helped
him with his next acquisition of a big
company gave him tax breaks all this
stuff it seems like you two are still
tied closely together i don't know about
the other one they're 100 tied closely
together and they're using it to
influence i guess what i'm saying is
like it's not like putin put these
people about they were already
billionaires they were already oligarchs
before putin's even empowered putin does
this [ __ ] [ __ ] and now you're taking out
it out on the people that are closest to
him right i don't know it's weird it
weirdly seems like
it really seems unfair
i think the lesson is if you look at
like how tied in like london's like
economy is to sort of like russian
oligarch money it's
kind of scary so i i think that's kind
of the lesson that i take from this is
be careful with who you get into
business with i think i i got approached
on a couple nft projects thought about
it and then kind of was uh
you know it's like you can definitely
sort of grab the bag but it ties you
into that forever yeah and i think the
more and more when we compromise uh
ideology for sort of economic gain
there's always the price to
bear
and
so it's like
those guys made some compromise
decisions and
is it fair no but are they responsible
for those decisions and the affiliations
they have
yeah is it a compromise decision
it depends on who you ask like uh i
think it's a compromise decision to
maintain the power but like buying a
oil
business from the government a pennies
on the dollar i don't think that there's
anything compromising about that anybody
would do that right but you also knew
that this was part of the the risk that
eventually could come due
like this wasn't unforeseeable didn't
mean it was likely or you didn't know
when but
if you get a pit bull and it bites
somebody like
you were hoping not you were trying to
train against this you were planning
against it but it doesn't mean you're
not responsible for the decision that
you ultimately took on
meaning them putting putin in power yeah
right yeah
it's an economic war right like i don't
know if you can necessarily search for
fairness in an economic world that's
true yeah can i tell you as a sports fan
it's weirdly kind of justice if you are
a fan of like the poor team because it
seems like all soccer is the richest
team wins all the championships and i
think i read chelsea hadn't won a
championship in almost 50 years then
this guy shows up puts two billion
dollars into the team and they won five
cents since 2003. so as like a team if
you root for like a poverty franchise
you're looking at them like you know
what [ __ ] you now you know what it's
like for the teams who don't have
billionaires who got their money through
these means and i know they're not the
only ones all the good teams are like
that but at least one team went down
yeah no i hear you
yeah i don't know why i don't know why i
just feel like it's uh
i mean i don't know why i even care
about like billionaires like they're
your contributors
are in contact with each other no it's
it's i'm not even trying to be
contrarian i just think it's like
undeserved it's like it's the same
reason why i don't want people [ __ ]
on like the russian people like they
don't want to be part of this
they want nothing to do with this right
right when i found out like tchaikovsky
was going to be removed from this uh
this like um opera or whatever and where
was it the whales or something like that
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] did
tchaikovsky have to do with any of this
yeah but tchaikovsky didn't get putin
put in power
you know what i mean if this guy was one
of the guys that got putin put in power
and is still tied to him right i'm with
you on tchaikovsky right
i understand more why abramovic is going
to get punished to be fair they thought
that they could
i'm just really interested in this part
of like uh history but like they thought
that they could control yeah and then
they they were wrong his pitbull analogy
works perfectly yeah the symbolic stuff
is stupid right like
oh we're not using russian composers in
the symphony yeah we all agree that's
like that's dumb yeah performance right
they took out poutine because it sounded
like that oh yeah
the french we're not even french the
quebecois like the fries with like the
cheese and gravy on it they're not
calling it poutine anymore because it
sounds so much like poop but we all
think the [ __ ] is that doing that money
is ultimately the thing that drives
everything right in the world so i think
fighting an economic war is just like
kind of getting right to the point of
what we all kind of think is controlling
things anyways you're saying modern
warfare is basically just it should be
fought economically yeah
but it's like bombing a country like
we bombed japan what did any of those
people in nagasaki have to do with
you know the world war ii or whatever
i mean the countries that have said that
we're at war with one another exactly
and if want it and russia's like yo
we're at war with ukraine and nato
it's like all right anyone that's
affiliated is involved in this economy
but did russia say that yet bombing the
country economically they just gave
people a chance to rebel without being
dead that's a great
it creates hardship that motivates them
for
making a change that's like led by the
people that actually live there without
being dead first
uh and obviously you know starvation and
lack to medical supplies and all those
things can be a big issue but
if
it doesn't mean it's perfect there's no
such thing i think as a surgical strike
really yeah everything has collateral
damage and it's more complicated than we
can imagine and it's better that that
collateral damage uh exists within the
billionaire class right of russian
oligarchs and not just the everyday
people who are
barely making it right like and when we
complain about oh well they're just you
know we're doing this just to try to
raise the stock price or this to this if
we all sort of if money comes to the
root of the motivations behind all the
things we complain about
that if we actually have like a big
escalating problem
let's just use money
you